where'd you get that Kill Bill poster
outside the big one the [__] that's
one of my favorites one of my favorite
movies it's the first thing I saw when I
walked in here I might steal it so
basically you know what dude if you want
it I'll give it to you oh wait yeah yeah
I will then I don't know what to do with
it are you serious yeah you swear I
swear to God you're gonna help you out
but can you feature him on a track yeah
easy we'll do that let's do that but you
love you when I first um walked into his
apartment that was like the biggest
thing well let me tell you this because
he's a giver I'm a giver I love giving
[__] so the fact that you just said that
right now you just made my [__]
day but let me explain why that means so
much but I'm not gonna wrap it and mail
it you have to take it I'm taking that
[__] yeah
of course so so I'm 13 years old living
in [__] I watch Kill Bill I see this
movie it's insane my mom she was like a
super bible thumper she's the type to be
like don't you ever take the lord's name
in vain God damn it [__] like
that yeah so there is no real reasoning
with her and we can get into that later
but
um I see this movie and it's just like
what you gave me and it's Escape it was
incredible you know what I'm saying it's
just this badass skinny [__] running
around slicing [__] up I'm like
yo this [__] is crazy and I watch it I
become obsessed with it and then I love
the music and I'm like oh my God this
music is insane and I see that the score
is done by RZA I'm like what the [__] is
RZA and then I do the time and take the
my due diligence to understand that that
actually stands for Rizza and the Rizza
is the founding member the Abbot of
Wu-Tang Clan so then through Kill Bill I
discover Wu-Tang Clan and then I
discover hip-hop then I start writing
songs and you know doing all this [__]
at 15 16 years old growing growing
growing and and then I get a record deal
and I do all these things because I saw
that one movie now we're talking about
manifestation here right so then later
on bro one of my best friends is the
Rizza of Wu-Tang Clan I I have every
single Living member on a track that I
did a few years ago called Wu-Tang
forever when I was a teenager in high
school I I said one day I'm gonna get
the entire Wu-Tang Clan on a song and
it's gonna be called Wu-Tang forever now
that's just one instance of this okay
you want to hear something really crazy
how about the uh the fact that
um I was never really into reading books
and then one book that I just became
obsessed with is is called Ready Player
One you guys have heard of that it's a
movie
so I read the movie I read the book I'm
obsessed with it I buy 50 copies I give
them to all my friends I give them to
fans all this other stuff I don't know
how I befriend the [__] author Ernest
Klein we become homies I find myself in
his home with his pregnant wife and his
children and all this is a shot of no
[__] idea how I got there he's in
Austin I'm there I guess I was on tour
I'm in his I'm in his DeLorean he's got
a flux capacitor shit's crazy the
[__] next book Ready Player Two comes
out I'm in the thank yous next to
Spielberg oh my God the other day a
couple weeks ago here's here's what's
really crazy A couple weeks ago right I
was supposed to do Jamie Kennedy's
podcast okay I was supposed to do that I
go to Nobu I canceled because I I had
some [__] come up but but we rescheduled
so we scheduled for a few days later I I
was thinking about Rosie O'Donald
randomly and I was thinking about Rosie
O'Donnell and how she is like a gay
woman
[__] bossed up especially in the 90s
and like can't what what's funny no
because I think this happens to me a lot
so now okay watch wow so so I'm like was
thinking about how she's just a [__]
boss how she represented herself the
same way Ellen y'all ever see when Ellen
did Oprah that [__] was crazy and
everybody was like [__] on her and
super homophobic and it was wild and
that this is with this woman endured in
the 90s as as a as a strong prominent
actor and she was herself anyway and
that [__] inspired me as a kid I'm
watching Harry at the spy and all this
[__] and I'm like oh my God and I was
randomly thinking about her a couple
weeks ago and I was thinking about how
[__] cool Rosie O'Donnell is and then
I had a dream
two days after that about Rosie
O'Donnell I don't know what we're doing
we're like playing chess with some
random [__] making love maybe no we
weren't and then I've had that dream and
then I go to [__] Nobu with my wife
guess who sits next to us Rosie
O'Donnell two days later two days later
and she sits there and I'm like oh my
God I really want to say something to
her did you
no I was a little nervous so and I just
I just wanted to respect her privacy so
I paid for a meal and I left her a note
and on that note it said something
really sweet that I don't I don't really
need to repeat because it's between me
and her so I I I I did that and she was
having lunch with a gentleman the next
day Jamie Kennedy texts me and goes you
out here buying Rosie O'Donnell lunch
and I go how the [__] do you know that
and he goes because the guy she was
having lunch with did my podcast the day
you were supposed to do it since you
couldn't make it he filled in for you
came and was like you ever heard of this
guy logic he's so nice and he goes no
way he's on my podcast tomorrow there
are no coincidences I'm just saying it's
like an M Night shop alone
I love it but isn't that crazy bro
that's one that's one example I could go
on and on and on and on and on the way I
said that this type of stuff that you're
explaining happens a lot to me for
instance like I was looking for the
number of nadav in your mom's house he's
a producer for your mom's house but then
I misspelled his name and I ended up
landing on my other friend Naveed and I
haven't really spoken in a year or
whatever like and then the next
literally within five minutes our friend
Jean Hong's like oh hey do you have
so-and-so's number which was naveed's
number wow and I was just looking at it
on my phone so these type of things
happen a lot and I wonder if it's
manifestation or just a little bit
witchy
you know like I've always my whole
family has always just described me as
oh like Lila she's witchy like if she
tiny things like that happen like it
just you can't explain it's like Harry
Potter yeah
so maybe you just have this kind of uh
like a little super power I don't think
I'm a warlock yeah but I do I I hear
what you're saying I think it's the
universe man I think it's the Universe I
think part of it is here I mean think
about this did you know that the stomach
if you just think about it it can slice
itself open did you know that did you
know that you can just cut your whole
stomach with your mind and bleed really